[Music]
welcome
everyone my name is jessica chung i'm an
admissions
officer at the stanford gsb
mba admissions office we're really
excited to
see you all online today we're going to
start with
some q a for our students and if you all
have any
questions for our panelists please feel
free to submit them using the q
a box and then after our students sign
off in about
20 to 30 minutes my colleague allison
and i are going to talk about
the admissions and application process
and make sure that you have all of your
questions
answered so we'll start with student
life and academics which our panelists
know well because they are living that
experience and then we will talk about
admissions and the application process
awesome so i'm going to ask our
panelists to introduce themselves
alan do you want to go first with your
name
um hometown pre-gsb location and your
favorite thing
about the gsb sure jessica
and hi everybody i wish we could see you
all but it's very hot it's very good to
be here i'm very happy to be able to
share with you i was in your shoes not
too long ago so it's very exciting
i am alan i'm a class of 21.
originally from mexico city born and
raised there came
from mexico city through gsb and my
favorite thing about the gsb is
definitely the people
interacting with people like eugenio
laura and
416 other classmates has definitely been
a
life-changing experience for me awesome
thank you lara would you like to go next
yes thank you jessica hi everyone
um definitely weird not to be able to
see
any faces but imagining you're all there
i'm laura i'm from venezuela
i was born and raised there and then
came to the us for college worked here
for a couple of years and then went back
home
um so i was coming from venezuela and
applied from there
to the gsb um i guess
let's see alan took the the typical
response of
favorite part of the gsb um definitely
people is
is up there um i guess to speak a little
bit
more specifically about activities and
and clubs at the gsb one highlight for
me has been the
gsb impact fund i would definitely
recommend
you all to check it out it's a way of
building a community of people who
are interested in learning more about vc
investing
in the and impact
both socially and environmentally truly
has been a highlight
of my time here so far
that's awesome thank you so much eugenio
would you like to go next
thanks jessica um hello everyone i was
just telling allison that
exactly two years ago i was exactly in
your shoes and so
uh this is exciting to now be on the
other side and be able to do this
um i'm from monterey mexico i was born
and raised there
after that i worked some for a bit in
new york and finance and i went uh to
work
in mexico in my hometown in brand
management
and then i transferred to vietnam
also working with brand management
um for heineken so i applied
i applied to the gsb from from vietnam
and um
my favorite thing about the gsb other
than the clubs
and the people is i would say the energy
uh around around campus and what i mean
by that is
i feel like if if you are looking to
potentially get involved in venture
capital
you there's there's this energy that
that you can quickly get enveloped in
if you wanna if you wanna potentially
explore
a startup there's all these all these
other people
that are willing to help you and uh give
you feedback
and surround you uh with good ideas so
that's what uh that's what i would say
just one one quick thing because neither
laura or
myself said it definitely the quality of
the professors and the speakers are
tremendous
just being able to sit in a classroom
with with our peers but at the same time
with the professors that we have with
the guest speakers and lecturers that we
have is just tremendous so
on the academic side that for me like
it's included in the people but
to the quality and the insight we get
from them
and how deep we can have conversations
with them it's tremendous
100 awesome that's awesome thank you all
so much for those responses
and if i may go a little bit off script
just to build on
some of the um experiences that you all
have brought up do you have
example or favorite examples of times
you've worked with faculty or
a favorite example of a time when you
helped one of your peers or somebody
else helped you
i think those kinds of stories i think
would add a lot of color and
help our attendees understand what it's
like to be at the gsb
definitely this is a real community in
which people help
each other just to give a clear example
on what jessica was saying
for me when i was looking for jobs
for summer internships last year
i went and i mean i had a couple of
conversations with
two professors not to ask me for a job
or anything like that just to like ask
for
advice and guidance on what type of
decisions i should make
because i had a couple of questions on
whether i wanted to do finance and what
type of like investment role i wanted to
do
and and reaching out to two professors i
was able to talk to them
they gave me some amazing advice and not
only that but also they ended up
introducing me to like a partner at the
firm where i actually ended up
entering on the summer and and i feel
like that's what definitely something
you get when you're here
you reach out to people for advice and
they not only give you advice but also
they will have you on the top of their
mind and then once something arises
they will think of you and they will put
you in touch with the right person
that maybe will put you in touch with
the right person that will end up
like being something good for you so
feel free to reach out to different
people
both where you're at right now and then
once you're here hopefully you all make
it
it's reach out to professors and and
classes above you because it's a real
community
yeah and just to second that i have two
very quick examples
um six months ago roughly when i was
a job searching for jobs for
for the summer um i wanted to work for a
company
and the only alumnus that i found was
on the board so very very senior
executive for a
large multinational corporation and i
reached out
and he was fun again from the gsb
graduated maybe 20 some years ago
and he immediately put me in touch he
said it's great to
get in touch with you thanks for for
your interest i'll
make sure human resources has your name
and uh i was able to go on to interview
with the company
so that was really surprising even
though they
they even though alumni have graduated
several years above us they're still
super engaged in the uh
with the current students and alumni and
the other
example i would give is recently we had
a
compressed course that lasted a week
and there was an in-person component and
i wasn't going to be able to attend
and so i reached out to professor
rob siegel who teaches the industrialist
dilemma
fantastic professor and by the way and
he
he said oh don't worry about it but why
don't you and i grow and grab lunch uh
next week uh and so we we had a socially
distant
and launched and just a fantastic
relationship
that i've been able to build with with
uh professor siegel
uh and he was the one who reached out to
me offering the
the lunch so it just shows the openness
and friendliness
of the community that's awesome
thank you all for sharing those stories
um so now
thinking back to um
i don't know a year or two ago 2018 for
eugenio
um how did you decide to apply to
stanford gsb
um i i can i can take that one um
i guess so i was telling allison two
years ago i
i did i visited several schools
uh stanford among them and i went
to the search fund the search fund class
entrepreneurial acquisition and i just
found that the teaching methods that i
encountered at the gsp
were much more effective to my learning
i felt
uh that this this class in particular
had
a lot of role-playing and so immediately
they asked a
person to spontaneously give a speech
on how they would address a company that
they had just acquired
and just having seen the student be put
on the spot like that
i felt like that was the type of uh
uncomfortable situation that i wanted to
be in uh and that was
that's how i learned best so i would say
the the
variety of teaching methods that i
encountered
awesome thank you i'm happy to share as
well my experience
so i went to every single school that i
wanted to apply
and when i came to the gsb
i first of all i spoke to a lot of
people
and i could already sense the the
the type of community that was here and
then i was able to as eugenio mentioned
he took the entrepreneurial equation
class i took the information of the
adventure class
which is one of the best classes at the
gsb
basically it's about entrepreneurship
and and some sort of venture capital
and it was at a time where i was about
to raise money for a project i was doing
with a couple of partners
and and i get here and professor stands
up
in the middle of the classroom and says
okay as you guys know today
it's not going to be a regular class
we're not going to teach anything
we have two alarms from like class of
whatever 2017
coming and they're going to pitch to
this other alum jeff crowd one of the
best
venture capitalists in the world and
they're going to pitch to him
they want to raise a million dollars and
this is going to be an actual pitch day
and jet will stop them and will tell
them what they're doing right what
they're doing wrong will explain to the
classroom
like what can they improve on and and to
me it was a mind-blowing experience just
i was at a point in time when i had to
go and raise money from investors and i
came here and it to me it was like
playing soccer with pele or whoever you
might think is the best soccer player of
all time
it was just impressive i and i thought
that if i was able to get
like the amount of mind learning
experience that i knew i was gonna get
here
was without a doubt the best in the
world so that's when
to me was clear that stanford was the
place for me
it's interesting choice of soccer player
so for me i didn't have the opportunity
to come to the gsp
before applying so i did most of my
research online and talking to people
who
had been to to this school um
i think for me so i was working in at
the time
in venezuela in social entrepreneurship
and so i wanted a school where
i knew that this was a focus
or an area that was important
even though i wasn't sure i wanted to
continue working in social
entrepreneurship
i knew that i wanted to be with
like-minded people who would want to
still work in business but have kind of
a perspective
towards impact and so to me it was just
very clear
how the gsb was superior
um in this sense and and yeah i
definitely recommend
talking to as many people as possible in
all schools that you're interested in
because that really helps shape
what the culture looks like and what
people
[Music]
just where their mindset is at at
different schools and it does differ
among schools
awesome thank you all so much for those
responses
um i have one more prepared question and
then we'll get to
attendee q a i'm wondering what's one
thing you wish you knew
going into the gsb or into the
application process
um i'm happy to take that one anita
actually answers
uh one of the uh questions that i see
from
from the attendees which is um
so i came from a i was a brand manager
at uh
at heineken uh beer company and
i felt that maybe that was an
untraditional uh job background given
given my focus on marketing i didn't
know of many
people who who had gone to the gsp from
marketing
and uh i was quite surprised to find
that
there was a huge variety of uh job
backgrounds
of course there are a lot of consultants
and finance backgrounds and
entrepreneurs
but i would wouldn't say they i would
say there's
a large large percentage
of people just from non-traditional
backgrounds
i i know people who um who
worked in in restaurants and were in a
in a bakery i know pro athletes
uh just a huge variety and i wouldn't
say that
that some or others are at an advantage
or disadvantage
uh to the gsb application
yeah i'll be very quick on this one and
it would respond my sex question and
then
i think mariano's question or clearly
that question
and and i agree with kenya basically if
you're 37 years old
the gsb is for you if you don't have any
finance or business experience in the
past the gsb is for you
that's what i wish i knew before i mean
i went to law school in mexico i'm a
former lawyer
i worked as a transaction lawyer for
five years and it might have seemed that
it was very hard to get to the gsb
without like being in private equity or
consulting or
whatever people think that's the right
path
the gsb is made of 416 or whatever the
number is now people
they all think differently they all are
different they all come from different
backgrounds they all come from different
places they all have different ages and
diversity is real and that's what i wish
i knew
before applying it it might look like
you're going uphill but you're not like
you just have to focus on
what you are best at what really
describes you
what you can bring to the community and
and that's enough you don't have to
fit into one box you just have to be the
best version of yourself
yeah definitely agree with all of that
um
and i guess one tactical thing i wish i
did
since the start of the gsb was
just constantly reaching out to people
and
learning about what they do especially
people who come from very very different
backgrounds than me and i think this is
something that
we all do and are still doing
but something that i always wish i did
even more because
even from the most random conversations
like just a 20 minute chat or grabbing
coffee with someone that
is from a totally different background
than you you actually get to
learn and it builds on your ideas of
what you want to do after
school or um yeah it's just
extremely enriching to your perspective
awesome thank you all for those
responses so we have another
we've had um there's a question about
career resources especially given
visa and work permit limitations so have
any
of all been able to draw upon some of
the career advising and career
management resources
have you navigated that and there are
also a couple questions
about social impact and
entrepreneurship so if any of you have
interests or experiences in those spaces
it sounds like our attendees are really
interested in those areas
too yeah i can answer quickly on the
visa
um so we now have three years of opt
as an international student you are you
can legally work in the us for three
years after graduation
so that's a huge change from what it was
two years ago in terms of working in
startups
interning in them or working at them
after school at least i'd be curious to
hear from eugenie and alan but i haven't
faced any sort of limitations because of
not being an american citizen
so i think this is more a consideration
for
three years down the road what will
happen like either you
if you will have a path towards a green
card which
that's typically offered by larger
companies startups it's something that
you either have to negotiate or
have a conversation about but at least
it's not an immediate concern
right after graduation
yeah i agree with laura i think um while
i was applying for jobs
this summer i received
i don't remember any company
explicitly excluding me from the process
because i didn't have a
long-term visa especially because cpt is
a known concern and
opt is now extended um for one year plus
the two stem
stem stem years
uh i would also i actually want to
change
maybe my favorite thing about the gsb is
the career management center
the cmc is has been incredibly helpful
and there's a ton of advisors there with
whom i built
personal relationships with and uh
they're super helpful they oftentimes
are gsb
graduates so they are within the network
and they know
a lot of people you could you can reach
out to so
they're they've been an incredible
resource uh for me
in terms of applying uh for jobs this
summer and also thinking about
jobs post mba
jessica maybe go to the next one i mean
they answered everything that was on
that question so
sure yeah we had another
great question about how
classes are structured have they been
are they oriented around teamwork and
collaboration
and are you would you all be able to
share maybe a
let's see what does this say uh perhaps
share
an example of a class that you really
liked that you've taken so far
sure i i can start with that one and i
mean i would encourage all of you to go
to the
gsd webpage i mean there is like
everything is there and if you do some
research you'll get to understand
everything
but i'll just explain quickly so
basically first quarter
you get like core classes and and some
of them
are based on individual assignments some
of them
are based on group assignments and exams
but they all are i would say they all
have a component
on a frontal class like
the professor teaching things as well as
students returning cases and
participating
er participating and giving their
opinion on cases
so all of them have both components and
then
the later you get into your gsb
experience the more you can
start choosing your classes you get to
choose electives in second quarter
not all your classes but some of them at
least
and then you can really go and take the
classes that you want
and focus on the topic that you're more
interested in
and then the classes are structured
basically in a way in which
you learn from the professor you learn
by yourself preparing cases
and you learn from your peers and guest
lecturers
in the discussion i would just highlight
there uh obviously there's a as allen
said there's a huge variety in terms of
teaching
methods but i would like to highlight
that
i feel like a big advantage of stanford
um
is that each each topic or each class
is tailored to the to what comes to what
stanford considers the best teaching
method for it
and these are even sometimes changing uh
very frequently
whereas other other schools have a more
uh more inflexible teaching methods
either more traditional case based
uh or more technical
lecture method or socratic method uh so
i i really
appreciate that because for example
accounting something that i would have a
hard time
learning by the case method uh
obviously this is a personal thing but
well i saw a couple of questions on the
social
entrepreneurship and social impact side
of things i think
for me key difference of the gsb
compared to other schools was classes
such as formation of impact ventures and
the gsb
impact fund and just in general i think
that the
environment i guess that energy that
eugenio was talking about at the
beginning
around the gsb in terms of impact um
to me felt really attractive
and thinking about impact as a
sustainable
uh a sustainable businesses that can
also be for-profit like
i i sin in my time here i've kind of
stepped away from more like charity
foundation
stuff to being more like i want to have
a business that is for-profit that can
like
apply for vc funding and be competitive
but
whose impact in the world like is
important and
that has that lens into measuring impact
just like financial returns
yeah i think that's a great segue into
another great question
one of our attendees submitted so ann
asks
what what do you consider the biggest
difference from the plans you
have currently and the plans you had
before
so how has gsb perhaps changed your
plans
professionally i
i mean that is the best question
i've heard so far today uh
when you're here just no i know for real
and they're both nothing because
probably they think the same way as i do
or because i've spoken too much we don't
know which one it is
but yeah i mean once you're here the
world opens for you
and the world opens for you in ways
which you didn't know the world
could open you think
you want to do x and then you end up
doing
maybe like x times a thousand times or
you end up doing y
or you just realize that x is just not
for you and
you end up doing something totally
different or maybe you actually end up
doing x but you end up doing x
at the best place in the world or with
the best people in the world
so it really opens like so many
opportunities and
one professor says something very cool
that is
along the lines that you will make good
choices as long as you have good
opportunities and he's like one of the
best advisors at the gsb
and his whole argument is that once
you're here you really look
into good opportunities and therefore
making decisions is
easy
awesome thank you for that insight
do you want to add anything else or
i was just sure i just wanted to say i
was laughing because my plans have
changed
dramatically uh almost once per quarter
once or twice per quarter
since i arrived i came from brand
management then i arrived and i wanted
to do venture capital
then i decided maybe private equity and
then i said no
maybe search funds and then
while i was applying uh for jobs i was
looking at uh
product management roles and uh retail
jobs
uh amazon and then i even considered
going back to brand management
i did venture capital for the summer now
i'm considering
doing a startup uh
and i mean from until graduation
plans might change again several times
but yeah
laura please please tell me why you're
laughing
i mean you want to go ahead i was just
thinking because we have
not that much time left i know and i i
see a lot of questions
maybe i mean this is not planned but if
you know laura maybe we can answer them
like very quickly so
we give them the like and
and i see a lot of questions on
financial aid there's a very cool
uh i mean financial aid is there for
whoever needs it
but that will be fair to the admissions
office to
answer those in a better way there's a
very cool
initiative that if you're from latin
america and you earn less than
i think 40k a year the admission a fee
is waste and there are other perks
of that so like feel free to have
admissions from that
help laura you have more answers i feel
like
no no she's gonna say you forgot about
another co-president of lasa it's not
just you and eugenio it's also me
but i'm sorry i didn't i say laura who
came in a new story i
i thought i said this to you about um
yeah i'm just i'm seeing other questions
on like
team work or like how classes are
structured
and i think in that sense it varies a
lot in a lot of classes you do have
projects that are in teams and so you
will work with your team outside of
class
but then others are more individual work
i guess it it varies a lot
and i know and you were talking about
before like at the gsb there's
a very it's it's not just the case
method it varies a lot depending on what
fits better for each subject so that's
great like you'll learn
in the way that that professor is better
at teaching and then
also what fits better in the subject so
it just varies a lot
awesome thank you all so much so we do
have a presentation on
admissions and we will talk about
financial aid as part of that
presentation
i know we could probably spend all day
asking about your experiences
at the gsb but i do want to make sure we
make time for
talking about admissions in the
application process so for our panelists
if you have any
parting words of wisdom you would like
to share i'm sure our attendees would be
all ears
if you have anything you'd like to say
before signing off
i guess just that it's worth
working hard to try to get into a place
like this
um i think i speak for the three of us
when i say that this
being here has changed our lives and
so yeah um i mean if you're thinking
about it if you're doubting it to apply
or not i would definitely
motivate you to go for it because it's
worth it
speaking on behalf of the three best
presidents of lhasa right
exactly
my my only piece of advice would be like
as laura said
any of you if you feel like you belong
here then
you will most certainly belong here
just be yourself on the application
uh try to show your true colors as soon
as possible
stanford loves diversity stanford loves
different people with different
backgrounds different thoughts so that's
that's very cool so don't
don't be scared of it and hopefully i
mean the three of us were in your shoes
two years ago
attending these these home meetings or
in-person meetings
and now we're here and we have all
different backgrounds we come from
different places
so like good luck with it and i'm sure
that if you work hard you
you will be here and we'll be happy to
help you out with anything
yeah i think the beauty of the gsb is
once you're part of the community
you're you're kind of always part of the
community so for those of you who apply
and
enroll here these amazing students will
soon be alums of the gsb and will
continue to be connected
to our community so awesome
thank you all so much for joining us
thank you so much good luck
bye good luck good luck guys
feel free to continue submitting
your questions and answers um hopefully
we'll cover a lot of the
the questions you're you're wondering
about in this presentation we're really
going to focus on
admissions and we'll talk a little bit
about the application process and the
financial aid process
as well and then save some time at the
end
for your questions so
our hope in having you all hear from
some of our students
is to help you get a sense of
how the gsb can help you do whatever it
is that you really want to do i think
their students shared
there's such a diversity of professional
backgrounds and interests
coming into the gsb and it's an
experience that really changes the
way that you think about the world
the opportunities that are available to
you and it might even change the goals
that you have for yourself
ultimately the purpose of this
experience is help you to achieve those
goals
whatever they are however they might
morph and transform
during your time here so i hope that our
students gave you a sense of
how this experience can do that for you
and now we want to talk about the
admissions and application process
this third question of can i get in
to stanford gsb
and so i know for most of you have
already started an application and that
is great
we hope that you feel that stanford is
the right place to take the next steps
in your professional journey and we want
to tell you a little bit about that
application process and make sure you
have all of your questions answered
what do we look for in applicants and
how do we evaluate your
application i know we are covering a lot
of ground today
um and remember you can always refer to
our website or reach out to our office
if you have any questions and as you
navigate this process we are here to
help you
and we dispense this advice for free
we are in your corner to help you
understand how we look at applications
so i'll begin by saying that there's no
formula for getting into the gsb
our students come from so many different
professional and academic backgrounds
they represent so many different
interests and goals and life experiences
just as there's no single path through
or beyond the gsb
there's no single path to the gsb as
well
instead the things that unite our
students and that we look for in our
applicants here
are intellectual vitality demonstrated
leadership potential
and personal qualities and contributions
we practice what's called
a holistic admissions process
no single component of the application
or the admissions process is the most
important we really look at every single
part of the application
before we make a decision on your
application
so we're really interested in the whole
person
and as i said before what we're really
looking for are people who demonstrate
intellectual vitality leadership
potential and personal qualities and
contributions
so so to say a little bit more about
what
those um what what that means
intellectual vitality refers to your
academic
aptitude and your academic attitude
our approach to assessing your
intellectual vitality
is also holistic it's not just your
um test scores it's not just about the
grades that you received in university
we're really interested
holistically in how you learn
who you are in the classroom what you're
passionate about
how do you apply yourself when something
really really interests you
so we have a holistic admissions process
generally and when we think about
a student's academic aptitude and
academic attitude coming into the gsb
we also apply that holistic approach
it's not just about one single thing
we look at demonstrated leadership
potential as i mentioned
when we're evaluating your application
we look at how you have exhibited
leadership behaviors like
strategic thinking initiative
persistence
results orientation how do you engage
other people
how do you develop other people and
support other people that you work with
we are looking for times when
you have used these behaviors to create
impact
or change in the organizations you're
involved in
and ultimately this is all about what
you have done
and how you have done it you don't
necessarily need to have had
a leadership role or a leadership title
to have demonstrated these leadership
qualities
instead we're really interested in how
you've created
positive change in the organizations and
the communities that you're in
regardless of your role you might have
heard the saying
show don't just tell and that really
really applies here
i think we are interested in
what you have done and how you have done
it so
detailed illustrative examples are
really really helpful to us
and we'll dive a little bit more into
demonstrated leadership potential in
just a moment
too and finally we're also interested
in your personal qualities and
contributions
we like we want to know who you are not
just what you've done
we want to learn more about your values
beliefs
your identity your passions your
experiences
we're really interested in the
perspective you will bring to our
classrooms and to our community
that will enrich the experience for
others i think as our
students describe so much of the
learning happens between students
we have an incredible faculty here as
well but
our students really really learn from
one another so it's important to us to
admit people who are going to contribute
to that
community we're going to contribute to
that
educational environment and help our
students learn from one another
so i mentioned demonstrated leadership
potential i do want to talk about that
aspect a little bit more because i think
i think it can seem a little
less straightforward our framework for
understanding your demonstrated
leadership potential includes
four competencies we're interested
in how you think have you had insights
or ideas that have made a difference to
a project that you've worked on or to
your team
or your organization or even your
industry
how have you impacted your
organization or your community through
the insights or ideas that you've had
we're interested in how you achieve do
you exceed expectations and set
challenging goals for yourself
are you persistent even in the face of
obstacles
do you produce results for your
organizations and for your communities
we're interested in how you engage
others this is all about
getting people on board have you been
able to motivate
others mobilize other people collaborate
with other people
towards achieving a common goal
and we're also interested in how you
develop other people
have you helped other people succeed or
have you
pursued efforts to improve the work
environment or your team culture such
that more people are able to perform
better and achieve their goals
so again we're we're interested in what
you've done and how you've done it
regardless of your role or title
and this hopefully gives you some
guidance in how to talk about the ways
you've demonstrated leadership
in your organizations and in your
communities
this is just another recap for
demonstrated leadership potential and
how we think about it
so just to recap again sort of the three
central qualities that we look for
in our admissions process are
intellectual vitality
demonstrated leadership potential and
personal qualities and contributions
and where do we find it there are many
different parts to the application and
as i mentioned earlier
this is a holistic process we consider
all parts of the application and making
our
admissions decisions so to that end we
look at your education we ask for
a unofficial copy of your university
transcript
and any other graduate or relevant
coursework we don't have any
preferred majors or areas of study and
we don't have any minimum
grade point average or rank in class
again our
approach to evaluating your academic
aptitude and academic attitude is
holistic so we look at all of it
we also ask for test scores we require
either the
gmat or the gre which must be taken
before the application deadline
we have no preference between these two
tests and there's no
required minimum score for either the
gmat or the gre
if your college or university teaches
classes
in a language other than english we do
require a language proficiency test
so either the toefl the ielts or pte
and again our approach to evaluating
your academics and your
application is holistic so your
education and your test scores
it's just one piece of a bigger puzzle
we also ask for a one-page resume and a
list of your activities
we look at your activities and your work
history
from your first year of university
onward
any internships you've had part-time
work full-time work
any clubs or activities things you may
have done in school
in the community or at work those are
all things we want to know about
as our students mentioned we have no
preferred industries
functions or types of activities we
welcome
a community of students that is diverse
in the broadest terms and that includes
their work experiences
and professional experiences
we're more interested in the impact that
you have had
in the organizations you've worked in or
the communities you've worked in
um so that is more impact is more
important to us
than the name or stature of your
organizations
and we'll also note that
activities and work experience are not
necessarily required for
mba program some students do apply
during their last year of
university for deferred admission
so that is an opportunity as well we
ultimately we welcome applicants at
all points in their career and we have
no we have no preference for when
an applicant applies to the gsb
um really what's more important is that
you apply when you feel ready
to take this next step in your
professional journey
we also ask for two letters of
recommendation
one from your current direct supervisor
or next
best alternative from work we're very
understanding if you're in a situation
that prevents you from
getting a letter of reference from your
direct supervisor
and the second letter of recommendation
is from someone else who has supervised
your work
letters of recommendation are so helpful
to us for getting a sense of
how you work with other people what sort
of how do you
perform in a work environment what sort
of results do you produce
how do you how do you demonstrate
leadership all of those things that
we've already
talked about so it is worth putting some
thought into who you will ask for those
letters of recommendation
and finally we have two essays that help
us learn about who you
are not just what you've done we want to
know the person behind the achievements
and your values your motivations your
aspirations
and perspectives so we have two essays
one that asks you the infamous question
what matters most to you and why and
then another essay that asks you
why you're interested in stanford gsb
if you have more that you would like to
share with us there are also
two optional short answer questions
which
ask about the positive impacts that
you've had
and your background and perspective and
these are truly optional questions
you're not required to submit answers to
these questions but
it's just another opportunity for you to
share with us
your story and then the final step
in the admissions process is the
interview which is
um by invitation only
so as alan mentioned
we do have a fee waiver program which we
launched this year we're really really
excited about it
um so as you may know it costs
275 dollars to submit your application
to
the stanford gsb however we do
offer fee waivers for applicants who are
from latin america and that includes
puerto rico
the caribbean islands central america
mexico and south america including
brazil
um so if you're from latin america any
of those areas that i just mentioned
and you make less than 40 000
per year your mba application fee will
automatically be waived
in the 2020 to 2021 application year
when you submit your application
and so this is one way that we're trying
to ensure
access equity and excellence at stanford
gsb
so a few of you had asked about
financial aid
and there are a few there are a few
central considerations when we talk
about financial
aid at stanford gsb one is that our
admissions process is need blind
that means we do not consider your
financial need
nor your personal resources for
financing your education
in our admissions decisions applicants
are admitted to the gsb
based on merit not whether or not they
can afford
to attend after you're admitted to the
program
our financial aid is entirely need based
our financial aid office looks at each
student's ability
to pay and allocates money based on who
needs it the most
obviously obtaining an mba is a
significant investment
in you and your future and we want to
make sure that that
investment is a reasonable one our
financial aid accounts for both
tuition and living expenses and
ultimately there are three guiding
principles
um that guide our need-based financial
aid approach
one is access we are committed to making
business school a reality for all of our
students
two is equity we want to make sure that
the process treats students fairly and
equitably
and third is excellence we want our
financial aid
to support our broad efforts to attract
a competitive
and diverse class
so to that end we award about 20 million
dollars
of fellowship money each year a
fellowship is essentially
a financial aid grant that we do not
expect you to pay back
the average annual need based fellowship
is about forty thousand dollars per year
or eighty thousand dollars over your
two-year mba experience
in addition to the fellowship money
there are many other financial aid
programs available to students
both international and domestic
including
other external scholarships or
the new stanford bold fellows fund which
augments need-based financial aid
in support of stanford university's
commitment to diversity equity inclusion
and while fellowships can reduce your
debt burden
we also offer loans for all students and
a very
generous loan forgiveness program after
graduation
for students going into the social
sector at any point in their career
so we hope that today's session has been
helpful in answering some of your big
questions about applying to stanford gsb
to continue on we encourage you to check
out mystanford.nbc
you can take a short quiz to personalize
your dashboard
you can keep track of your application
progress and events
and find out about other find out
other information about stanford
tailored to your interests
so next my colleague allison and i are
going to take your questions which you
can submit in the q a box
jessica there's one question here that i
think we should answer from
jimmy who wants to understand the
process of how to apply for the fee
waiver
yes that's a great question so the fee
waiver will be
automatically applied if you are a
citizen of
a latin american country or a country in
the regions that i named earlier
and your salary converts to
40 000 or less
in u.s currency so that's that happens
automatically if you
um if you feel that the
fee waiver should apply to you but it's
not happening automatically
feel free to reach out to to our office
we want to make sure that
you're able to access that program so
susanna asks does
the minimum gmat score depend on the
industry
and so i'll preface this by saying
there's no minimum
gmat score you can take a look at our
class profile on our website if you want
to get a sense of
where most of our students fall in terms
of their scores but
there's no minimum score and as i
mentioned this is a holistic
process so for as much attention as
scores get
ultimately we're really interested in
the whole person
part of that is determining whether or
not you
have the academic preparation to
[Music]
succeed in our classes but again
it's a holistic process we're interested
in your
academic aptitude and your academic
attitude
and we look not just at your scores but
also how
how have you performed in the classroom
what grades did you receive in
university
did you challenge yourself and take
really rigorous classes
um even after graduation if you are
still
making an effort to prepare yourself for
graduate study these are all things that
we think about when we look at your
application
allison do you have anything to add yeah
i would just add please rest assured
that if your first language
is not english we're not going to expect
you know your
verbal scores on the gmat or the gre to
be as high as a native speaker so often
for international
applicants they're a little lopsided you
know where the quant is going to be
higher
and i did post the class profile in the
chat but this is the range of scores
in this particular class you know it
varies from year to year
and over the years we have had scores
down in the 500s i think the lowest
score i
ever saw in the class was a 450. i'm not
you know recommending you know aim for
450 but
uh the person did perfectly fine so um
uh you know just do the best you can and
and
don't you know don't be too concerned
the only minimums we have
for anything you know we don't have any
minimum work experience minimum anything
are the english book essentially tests
for obvious
reasons and i um i'll put those in the
chat with the minimums are there
but as you probably know american style
of education
going to be a lot of class discussion so
we we do need you to you know be fluent
before you get here
i see a couple of great questions about
the waiver
the fee waiver um
let me just make sure i'm i capture
there are a few different questions i'm
going to try to fold into one
so i think one question was about
whether you're eligible for the waiver
even
if you don't live in latin america
currently and the answer is yes
the fee waiver will be automatically
applied
if you have latin american citizenship
if you currently
work and live in latin america but you
don't have latin american citizenship
you can still reach out to us about
submitting
submitting a waiver request so
we absolutely want to make sure that
everybody who
needs the waiver is connected to that
opportunity and then there was another
question
about um
whether how how do we calculate income
so
number one we automatically convert your
income into
um us currency and
we're looking at your i guess your gross
or your net
income so both your salary base and
any additional earned income such as
such as bonuses
so we look at those two things together
what should people include in their
activities list
yeah with the extracurriculars um those
are just
either extracurricular activities you
did in university or in the community
and again you know we're very well aware
that for
um some international applicants you
know extracurriculars may just not be a
big part of your
university life or or uh you know the
community
so it's not something that you have to
have um it could also be something
more individual you know maybe you've
played the
bugle since you were six years old or
something like that so it's really um
extracurricular activities that could be
organized or just
individual kind of pursuits and hobbies
and sports kind of thing
another great question in here from
gabriella
about how basically how
can prospective students understand if
they're the right fit with the school
so i think hopefully today's session was
helpful
you have the opportunity to talk to some
of our students
we also have a more general information
session
that provides more of an overview of the
academic program and
is also accompanied by student panel so
that could be another opportunity to
learn more about the program and hear
from our students
there will be some overlap for
especially the part where we're talking
about admissions and financial aid but
that could be another opportunity to get
a sense if you're a good fit
um and i think as our students mentioned
people are so willing to help out here
so you can always reach out to our
office
if there is a student organization that
you feel an affinity for
you might be able to reach out to them
and see if they would be
willing to share a bit about their
experiences with you as well
um alison i think a great question
there are a couple questions about
partners if partners can
take classes um are there any programs
looking at that as well um officially
as a partner you wouldn't be able to
take gsb classes but certainly
your student you know could ask the
professor to let you sit in
on you know a single class or something
like that um the bechtel international
center
um at stanford has a a
huge range of sort of enrichment classes
and english classes
for partners and there you'd be meeting
uh you know partners from across
the whole university um and
there's in in the states you know
there's also
local junior colleges that are um
very low cost where you can take uh
uh classes as well but i think more
broadly
um your experience here you're really uh
an important part of the gsb community
um as a partner and there's a biz
partners organization there's biz kids
there's
gsb dogs you know so there's a lot of
inclusiveness there
and um you will you're invited to all
the extracurricular activities
um a lot of students tell me that
actually their partner
has more friends in the class than they
do because
of course you know you're you're not
having to take tests and study
and so you maybe have more time for the
socializing um
also um partners are so valued in our
community
that our admit weekend which is for
uh sort of an open house when you're
admitted to
to see if you know the school is right
for you the admit committee
is actually chaired by a student
and a partner that's how important
partners are and so there's a whole
um you know range of activities during
admit weekend that are specifically for
partners
i'll answer one more question and then
we'll let you all go
um but of course feel free to go if you
need to as well
so there's a great question in here um
from mariano who asks for
from what i've heard i infer we need to
be working in a company at the time of
application
is this correct what happens if my
current work is not very related with
what i want to do
so there are no
there's no activity or work experience
requirements
for applying to gsb as i mentioned
earlier sometimes we even have students
applying
right out of their university studies so
there's no
requirement that you are currently
working at the time that you apply
ultimately i think we are interested in
the impact that
you've had and that can be
um in any number of different types of
organizations communities
um so we don't require that
applicants are currently working at a
company at the time of their application
and it is also completely fine if the
work that you're currently doing
is different from what you want to do i
think a lot of people use
business school as an opportunity to
pivot into something new
gain new exposure use it as a launching
pad to accelerate their career so
for us it is completely fine if
your current work is not related to what
you eventually want to do and i think as
our students demonstrated
what you want to do could easily change
two three five ten times by the time you
want to graduate
um so rest assured that
that we understand that people change
paths i think ultimately this is a very
very human process we are the humans who
read your application
um and so we kind of we kind of get it
we know what it's like to be human
and to be trying to find your
path in the world jessica do you want to
take that last question from hector
about
applying for fellowships absolutely yes
um so hector asks if i need financial
aid would i need to apply
for admission to the program and
simultaneously to one of the fellowships
available or how does this process work
and that is a great question so first
you apply for admission
to stanford gsb and then once you're
admitted
that's when you submit your financial
aid application
so these are not processes that you need
to do simultaneously
once you get an admissions decision from
us that's when you apply
for um fellowships and you're not
applying for a specific fellowship
you're you're just applying for
fellowships in general and you don't
apply for a specific one
we've loved talking to you all today
thank you so much for joining us
we are here for you we are in your
corner this is not a process you have to
go through alone
you can always reach out to us thank you
all so much for being here it's been a
pleasure great meeting you all
best of luck take care bye bye now